Donald Trump's daily briefings aren't
short on controversy but he took this
one to new levels right and then I see
the disinfectant where it knocks it out
in a minute one minute and is there way
we can do something like that by
injection inside or almost a cleaning
because you see it gets in the lungs and
it does a tremendous number of along so
it'd be interesting to check that so
that you're gonna have to use medical
doctors with but it sounds it sounds
interesting to me in case you're in any
doubt that was the President of the
United States suggesting that injecting
disinfectant might be a way to treat
coronavirus it can't be said with enough
urgency that it is not his comments
prompted the manufacturers of Dettol and
Lysol to issue a statement that they
surely never imagined having to write in
these circumstances they said as a
global leader in health and hygiene
products we must be clear that under no
circumstance should our disinfectant
products be administered into the human
body through injection ingestion or any
other route Trump now claims he wasn't
being serious I was asking a question
sarcastically to reporters like you just
to see what would happen
put in the form of a question to a group
of extraordinarily hostile people namely
the faint news media the White House had
already tried to walk back the
president's comments with no mention of
sarcasm just accusations that
journalists were taking it all out of
context on Friday night he took no
questions an unusual move and one of the
shortest White House briefings yet
Donald Trump has repeatedly and
recklessly pushed what he sees as
potential cures first it was
hydroxychloroquine I've seen people that
are going to die without it and you know
the expression when that's happening
they should do what really do we have to
lose it turns out quite a lot a new
study found this
a drug has no benefit in coronavirus
treatment it actually saw a higher death
rate the Food and Drug Administration
has now issued a warning against it over
risks to the heart president and your
fake news the president knows his
powerful words reach millions of
Americans thank you
many of whom are desperately sick this
could actually be a lethal combination
Amanda Walker Sky News